[Musique]
au nom du Gouvernement de la
République cette
disposition
[Musique]
il est passé en force à la hussarde qui
ressemblait d'ailleurs à Jacques Chirac
il osait en fait ça a été une
déflagration politique l'annonce de la
suppression du service national au fond
il considérait le service militaire
comme dépassé et en particulier depuis
la chute du mur de Berlin et la
dislocation de l'Union soviétique on est
devenu orphelin c'est-à-dire qu'après et
bien tout le monde a commencé à discuter
sur la cohésion nationale ce qui est
vrai c'est que le service militaire
s'inscrit vraiment dans une mythologie
républicaine disons que c'est une
question de savoir si on recourt au
service militaire ou au contraire à des
forces armées professionnelles cette
question peut-être débatue encore
aujourd'hui pour terminer arrivons-en
maintenant au service national bon en
clair carrément est-ce que c'est la fin
du service national ou pas est-ce que
c'est la fin du service national ou non
le service
militaire a été créé en 1905 comme vous
le savez oui à une époque où il fallait
des poitrines à opposer à d'autres
poitrines si j'ose dire face à un danger
extérieur cette époque est complètement
révolu nous n'avons plus besoin
d'appeler de gens faisant leur service
militaire et donc dans 6 ans il n'y en
aura plus ou quasiment plus
nous sommes le 22 février 1996 et
Jacques Chirac en direct à la télévision
vient de lâcher une petite bombe qui va
changer la vie de millions de jeunes
Français c'est la fin du service
militaire l'annonce surprend dans la
défense comme dans la classe politique
car le même Jacques Chirac grand
admirateur de l'armée capable de
reconnaître le moindre galon sur un
uniforme avait adoré son année passée
sous les drapeaux en Algérie la période
la plus passionnante de son existence
selon lui celle où il avait appris à
commander et voilà que moins d'un an
après son accession à l'Élysée le
nouveau chef des armées choisit d'en
finir en quelques mots avec un héritage
de la Révolution française celui de la
conscription et avec un service
militaire vieux de plus d'un siècle qui
permit à la France de mobiliser des
troupes en temps de guerre mais aussi de
se forger une forme d'unité nationale ou
de brassage social en temps de paix
comment Jacques shirac a-t-il imposé ses
vu y compris dans son propre camp pour
doter la France d'une armée de métier
comment cette décision d'un président de
droite fut-elle mise en œuvre par la
gauche et avec quelle difficulté et puis
avions-nous bien mesuré à l'époque les
conséquences de cette réforme pour la
défense mais aussi pour l'ensemble de la
société c'est l'histoire que nous allons
vous
[Musique]
raconter bonjour jean-dinique merch
bonjour vous êtes journaliste à
l'opinion vous êtes un des meilleurs
connaisseurs des enjeux mais aussi des
coulisses de notre armée et en 1996 vous
couvrez la défense pour le quotidien
Libération d'abord cette intervention du
président Chirac au soir du 22 février
1996 ça a surpris tous les Français
est-ce que ça vous a surpris vous on
savait que des choses étaient en
préparation mais on ne savait pas que ça
allitêtre aussi fort que ça euh en fait
ça a été une déflagration politique
l'annonce de de la suppression du
service
national on suivait ça en coulisse et
puis tout d'un coup bah voilà c'était là
et effectivement c'était un un moment
fort un moment fort de la République et
un moment fort d'une carrière de
journaliste lors de la campagne
présidentiel de 1995 Jacques shirac àors
candidat avait promis pourtant de
réduire la durée du service militaire
pas de le supprimer ce n'est pas mon
propos de supprimer le service national
il doit cependant évoluer car il ne
correspond plus à ces deux Prin princip
fondateur l'égalité et l'universalité il
faut progresser vers une armée de plus
en plus professionnelle il faut étudier
la possibilité de réduire le service à 6
mois on savait que Jacques Chirac était
partisan de sa suppression mais on
pensait que les conditions politiques
n'étaient pas réunies pour le faire et
il est passé en force et c'est ça
l'événement de février
1996 c'est ce passage peu cavalier comme
ça à la hussarde qui ressemblait
d'ailleurs à Jacques Chirac il osait et
et tout à coup voilà il a imposé cette
cette décision contre absolument tout le
monde qu'est-ce qui motive sa décision à
l'époque alors il y a deux événements
géopolitiques majeurs il y a la première
Guer du golf en
90-91 et à partir de
1992 il y a les interventions militaires
dans l'ex Yugoslavie là on comprend à ce
moment-là que ce type d'intervention
militaire ne peut-être re le fait que de
militair professionnels ou volontaire
aucun appelé ne sera envoyé dans le golf
aucun appelé si ce n'est volontaire ne
sera envoyé en Bosnie à partir de 92
c'est pas la France qui est menacée en
tant que tel donc on n'engage pas les
jeunes Français dans ce genre
d'opération on dit que Jacques shirac
c'était ému de voir que la France
n'avait pas été capable d'envoyer plus
de 10000 hommes dans l'opération d'Aget
pendant la guerre du GO AB tout le monde
est ému par ça tout le monde se dit ça
peut c'est pas possible les premiers qui
engagent la transformation dès le
lendemain de la guerre de d'Irak de la
guerre du Golfe en 80 à partir de 91 92
ce sont les socialistes les éléments de
la division d'agué mêlés à ceux du 18e
corps d'armée américain n'ont pas
rencontré de vive résistance on voit pas
grandchose onentend pas grand-chose là
pour le moment tout paraî calme tout
parail cette fois ça y est nous sommes
au-delà de la ligne de démarcation à 3
km à l'intérieur du territoire iraakien
secret dès la la période la fin des
années Méran une armée professionnelle
une armée qui est capable d'intervenir
mais on décide à côté de ça de maintenir
le service national jusqu'à ce que
Jacques Chirac décide lui de la bolè au
lendemain de son élection Jacques Chirac
va demander à son ministre de la Défense
Charles mignon de réfléchir à la
suppression du service militaire un
ministre de la Défense qui pour la
petite histoire n'a pas fait son service
militaire lui-même et pendant plus de 6
mois la réforme est élaborée dans le
secret du Conseil de défense et rien ne
filtre rien de filtre et il va se passer
lors d'une réunion le 30 novembre 1995
quelque chose d'inédit Jacques Chirac
président va retoquer la copie qu'on lui
présente parce qu'elle défend
précisément un modèle d'armée mixte il
va le demander qu'on lui présente une
copie avec une armée entièrement
professionnelle absolument le vrai
basculement il est là il est il a laissé
travailler
les députés les ministres les
état-majors tout l'appareil d'État qui
au fond comme d'habitude dit bah on va
faire comme on a toujours fait
c'est-à-dire pas de réforme qui B nous
bousculer rit trop on va garder des
appelés puis on va avoir on va avoir une
armée avec des corps professionnels et
des unités professionnelles puis on va
quand même garder des appelet voilà bon
évidemment Chirac dit non mais vous avez
pas compris ce que je veux donc il
impose ça quasiment à la totalité de
l'échiquier politique y compris le
ministre de la Défense Charles Millon ou
des personnalités importantes à l'époque
comme Philippe ségin grand grand
Gauliste et à la totalité des
institutions militaires on n'entend pas
beaucoup de voix à droite à l'époque
s'élev contre le choix présidentiel oui
parce que c'est c'est un choix qui est
au fond très populaire si vous vlez
servic militaire très honnêtement quand
on l'a fait 20 ans après il il laisse
des bons souvenirs parce qu'on ne se
souvient que des moments joyeux et puis
c'était il y a 20 ans et puis le temps a
passé et puis quand on avit son service
militaire on est content que les autres
le fassent aussi je dirais par esprit de
justice en quelque sorte moi j'ai perdu
10ent les uns et les autres 18 mois 12
mois que les autres le fassent ça les
formera les petitsjeunes dans son
interview du 22 février le président
écarte la piste d'un référendum sur le
service militaire mais il annonce une
grande consultation nationale avec deux
scénarios envisagés par le président la
transformation du service militaire en
un service civique ou le remplacement du
service national obligatoire par un
système de volontariat il va y avoir
beaucoup de réunions plus de 10000 sur
les territoires en fait il a déjà fait
son choix bien sûr il noit le poisson il
essaie de il a bien compris que bon les
militaires obéiraient monong gré malgré
que les politiques cétaient moins sûr y
compris dans sa propre majorité donc il
est obligé de désamorcer tout ça et donc
il lance comme on fait quand on veut
désamorcer une crise ou une crise on
lance un grand débat tout ça c'est un
enrobage la décision est prise dès le
départ tout ça pour au final faire ce
qu'il était prévu depuis le premier jour
à Besançon jacquirac a commencé par
passer les troupes en revue comme un
symbole dans une ville et une région où
l'armée partout présente est aussi un
acteur de la vie économique avec ses
3500 emplois à l'heure du dîner devant
les parlementaires de la région majorité
et opposition il a encore été question
de défense et d'emploi cétait une scène
surréaliste car nous avions été invités
à la table de Jacques Chirac tous les
parlementaires qui pour la plupart
étaient des parlementaires RPR mais
Jacques shirac ne voulait pas leur
parler parce qu'ils s'étaient tous
prononcés pour baladure et shirac
semblait considérer qu'il n'avait qu'un
seul interlocuteur valable c'était moi
donc nous discutions du pour et du
contre du service militaire de son
historique euh nous revenions sur la
guerre de 70 les deux guerres mondiales
et la guerre d'Algérie et les raisons
pour lesquelles le général de Gaulle
s'était prononcé pour l'armée de métier
mais finalement quand avait eu la
possibilité après la fin des guerre
d'Algérie n'en avait rien fait donc
c'était une discussion tout à fait
passionnante il a fait semblant de
prendre avec beaucoup d'intérêt tout ce
que je lui disais j'avais presque le
sentiment
d'avoir marqué le point
évidemment décision était prise et le 28
mai 1996 après 3 mois de débat donc ce
fameux rideau de fumé don dont vous
parlez le président de la République
confirme sa décision dans une allocution
télévisée comment les militaires
réagissent-ils à la décision de Jack
sherac de supprimer le service militaire
plutôt mal plutôt mal parce que c'est
assez confortable le système tel qu'il
fonctionnait jusqu'en
96 d'abord c'était une armée plus
volumineuse donc qui dit une armée plus
volumineuse dit plus de postes de
commandement plus de de chef de corps
come on dit colonel commandant des
régiments plus de bases aériennes plus
de bateaux plus plus de débouché de
carrière plus de débouché de carrière et
puis c'est confortable parce que il y
avait du personnel qui plusit du
personnel souvent très qualifié
euh qui était disponible pour pas cher
et qui était assez peu contestataire on
va dire parce que il était obligé d'être
là et tout d'un coup cette ressource
elle disparaît donc évidemment c'est
compliqué c'est beaucoup beaucoup moins
confortable et donc évidemment il y
avait il y avait une
opposition assez corporatiste au fond à
à la fin de ce service ce service
militaire tandis que les politiques
débattent des contours de la future loi
les militaires accusent le coup dans la
tradition de la grande muette on fait
rarement part de ses opinions ou de ses
état d'âes alors encore moins s'il
s'agit de divergence avec le chef des
armées et pourtant la disparition du
service militaire et son corolaire le
passage à une armée de métier représente
une révolution qui va bouleverser les
habitudes de dizaines de milliers de
soldats bonjour beno pugard bonjour
monsieur vous êtes général d'armée qui
le rent l'appellation la plus haute dans
la hiérarchie de l'armée de Terre vous
avez une carrière militaire exemplaire
vous avez participé diton à quasiment
toutes les opérations extérieures au
cours de votre carrière vous êtes devenu
le chef d'étatmajor particulier de deux
présidents de la république Nicolas
Sarkozi François Hollande pendant 6 ans
un record de de longévité mais en ce
début de septaa Chirak euh vous êtes en
mission en
ex-yugoslavie et je voudrais commencer
cette interview en parlant de la boss
justement et d'un événement qui va
survenir 10 jours seulement après la
prise de fonction de Jacques Chirac et
qui va profondément marquer le nouveau
président on est le 26 mai 1995 à
sarievo plusieurs casques bleus français
sont pris en otage par l'armée serbe
pour servir de bouclier humain et
Jacques Chirac va découvrir effaré à la
télévision les images de ces soldats
français qui se rendent avec un drapeau
blanc a été choqué car c'est humiliant
de voir un officier et des soldats
français furent-ils sous casque bleu il
sait un drapeau blanc pour se rendre
donc pour le président Shirak a
effectivement été un un moment où il a
réalisé qu'il était réellement le chef
des armées et qu'il fallait prendre le
taureau par les cornes ce qu'il a fait
dans la foulée par des discussions des
négociations à la fois avec l'ONU à la
fois avec le l'OTAN dès le lendemain de
cette prise d'otage Jacques Chirac va
enfiler son uniforme de de chef des
armées si j'ose dire en autorisant une
repost 32 marsoin du 3è Rima vont
reprendre un pont le pont de Verbania
qui était un poste d'observation de
l'ONU occupé par par l'armée ser deux
soldats français ils perdront la vie
selon ses proches ces de jours ils vont
constituer un un événement fondateur
pour Jacques Chirac qui va peser dans
son choix d'une armée de métier l'action
militaire si vous voulez c'est une une
des options qui sont offertes lorsque
tous les autres ont échoué et qu'il est
nécessaire à un moment de défendre la
vie de nos compatriotes ou la vie
d'êtres humains ou encore de permettre
de défendre ses idéaux et il faut être
crédible et il faut être crédible et
pour cela ça nécessite à la fois un
entraînement un équipement mais surtout
un état d'esprit de vainqueur et c'est
ça qu'il a voulu remettre au sein de
l'armée de terre parce que moins d'un an
après cet événement donc nous sommes là
pour le coup en février 1996 il va donc
annoncer la fin du service militaire
comment vous réagissez quand vous
entendez ça mais en fait le ayant
participé en étant à l'état-major de
l'armée de terre à la rédaction directe
du Livre Blanc donc dit de
1994 la question avait été abordée au
sein des groupes de travail et il était
de notoriété publique que la tendance
lourde était pour une suppression
suspension du service national et donc
on sentait venir mais c'était àout ce
mot d'armée de métier à l'époque c'était
un peu tabou c'est surtout qu'il y avait
une confusion beaucoup de gens ont
considéré que le livre l'armée de
métiers de de gale était pour une armée
professionnel ce qui n'avait rien à voir
et que lorsqu'on lit l'armée de métier
on s'aperçoit que c'est pas ça le
simplement de Gaul disait
qu'effectivement conduire la guerre est
un métier et que ça s'apprend que être
artilleur qu'être cavalier qu'être
fantassin troupe de marine pilote
navigateur marin c'est un métier qui
s'apprend ensuite il y avait une
deuxième raison qui est é l'inégalité
des de nos concitoyens des hommes au
regard de de ce service national et il y
avait de plus en plus d'exention et donc
certains estimaient que le système était
devenu inégalitaire mais la vraie
décision qui a conduit justement à une
réflexion à une remise en cause du
service national pour moi c'est la
décision qui a été prise par le
président mitéan pendant la guerre du
Golf de refuser que les appelés même les
appelés volontaires
participe à la guerre du Golf et vous
voulez dire qu'en choisissant de ne pas
faire partir des appelés même
volontaires on c'était dé facto
reconnaître une forme de Ctait défo
considérer que au sein des armées il y
avait deux statuts le statut de de
d'active le statut de militaire de
carrière le militaire de métier et puis
le le statut d'appeler qui devenait
presque un supplétif puisque vous savez
que les supplétifs pendant la guerre de
14-18 étai ceux qui pour des raisons
notamment physique n'était pas à même de
porter les armes parce qu'il n'en avait
pas la la capacité ont quand même servit
les armées comme conducteur comme
magasinier et cetera quand Jacques
Chirac annonce la la la suppression du
service militaire quelle est la réaction
dans l'armée mais dans les discussions
vous aviez donc deux je dirais deux deux
camps vous aviez ceux qui restaient très
liés à l'armée de de conscription donc
aux appelés pour euh poursuivre la
formation nos concitoyens à l'esprit de
défense et puis vous avez les autres qui
estimaient précisément à cause de la
décision de pas engager les appeler au
combat disant donc les appeler servent à
rien puisque en opération extérieure on
peut pas les employer ça manque
aujourd'hui cette esprit de défense les
Français qui n'ont pas connu le service
national seraient-ils prêt à se défendre
dans l'hypothèse d'une attaque ou d'un
drame sur le territoire national la
question reste ouverte ensuite on perd
ce côté qui peut paraître un petit peu
désué qui est ce contact de toutes les
couches de d'une société c'était une
mythologie républicaine ou c'était une
réalité ça on peut toujours dire que
c'était une mythologie pour certains
bourgeois parisiens je suis né à Paris
j'étaéis élevé à Paris je suis un
bourgeois de Paris donc c'est pour ça
que je peux me permettre de le dire mais
c'était une mythologie oui pour ces
gens-là parce qu'ils faisaient tout pour
pas le faire et il
préférait courir la jeunes fille ou ou
rester avec les copains plutôt que
d'apprendre un métier et de d'avoir un
contact avec la troupe et voir le
commandement mais pour qui étai en
caserne mais pour ceux qui étaient en
caserne et qui étaient obligés les
témoignages sont là vous vous retrouviez
contraint et forcé de vivre ensemble et
là vous découvriez des gens aujourd'hui
les gens savent plus on vit dans un
petit peu dans notre cocon mais on n
apprend pas à rencontrer les autres les
ouvriers PEJ par exemple j'ai côtoyé
dans ma chambre
ou bien quand j'ai été élève officier à
l'école militaire de chercher en Algérie
j'ai pu rencontrer des gens extrêmement
divers qui me serait pas arrivé de
rencontrer donc il y a eu un brassage et
en même temps une
expérience
extraordinaire quand j'étais en
formation comme élève officier j'avais
un instructeur qui était un Français
d'origine Caby qui avait fait l'Indo qui
avait fait l'Algérie même si il avait
devant lui des étudiants avec bac plus 5
et lui devitre à
bac5 on le prenait au sérieux parce
qu'il parlait d'autorité et on se disait
que un truc ça ça pouvait nous arriver
un moment ou un autre ensuite il est il
est sûr
que lorsque vous on vous impose un impôt
qui est celui pendant 1 an de faire
votre service national on peut
comprendre que lorsque vous vous vous
destinez à une carrière même de
cuisinier que vous êtes apprenti et là
on vous prend pendant un an pour aller
apprendre à tirer dans les bois et à
vous promener avec un sac à dos sur le
dos évidemment vous vous regrettez parce
que vous êtes en train d'apprendre votre
métier vous gagnez pas d'argent vous
avez peur que la place disparaît que
vous la perdiez donc on peut comprendre
si vous voulez le désorois l'inquiétude
vous perdez votre famille puce qu'on
envoyit les gens à gauche donc on peut
comprendre cette inquié étude et
justement il fallait la prendre en
compte et je pense qu'elle a été
insuffisamment prise en compte notamment
après la la chute du rideau de fer et
donc les les gens ne voyaient plus
l'utilité alors quand vous avez un impôt
et en plus que c'est pas utile à la fin
de l'automne 1996 le ministre de la
Défense Charles Millon présente son
projet de loi sur la suppression du
service militaire au Conseil des
ministres le texte entame son parcours
législatif entre les deux chambres mais
le 21 avril 1997 Jacques Chirac à la
surprise générale annonce la dissolution
de l'Assemblée nationale avec le succès
que l'on sait le 1er juin la gauche
rafle la majorité des sièges au Palais
Bourbon lonnael Jospin le socialiste
s'installe dans le fauteuil de Premier
ministre un nouveau visage arrive à
l'Hôtel de Brienne au ministère de la
Défense et une question se pose la
gauche va-t-elle honorer cette promesse
qui n'était pas la sienne va-t-elle
faire cette réforme dont elle ne voulait
pas bonjour Alain Richard bonjour cher
monsieur vous avez été député sénateur
du valdoise mais en 1997 quand la gauche
revient au pouvoir vous êtes nomé
ministre de la Défense et c'est donc
vous dans les faits qui allez supprimer
le service militaire ou plutôt le
suspendre la loi qui organisait la
suspension du du service national était
presque entièrement voté puisque les
deux lectures avaient eu lieu à
l'Assemblée au Sénat et que il ne
restait plus au moment de la dissolution
que la commission mixte paritaire qui
forcément aurait abouti à un texte
commun qu'est-ce que vous dites à Lionel
Jospin et donc je lu dit à ton avis
avons-nous le choix de poursuivre cette
réforme ou de faire faire autre chose et
sa réponse avait été une grande comment
dire élévation démocratique il a dit
écoute nous n'avons pas eu de mandat
lors de notre élection pour revenir sur
cette réforme donc il faut l'appliquer
c'est une décision qui avait fait débat
au Parti socialiste alors je me souviens
très bien du débat que nous avions eu
donc probablement vers le printemps 96
après l'annonce de jacquesir ça allait
contre
une une pensée profonde je pres que dire
réflexe au Parti socialiste qui était la
fidélité à jores et à l'idée du citoyen
en arme une
conception sans doute un peu idéalisé de
ce quiétait révolutionnaire la
conscription voilà et donc il avait il y
avait la la la la pression psychologique
au sein de cette force de gauche et
c'était moins aussi net au sein du parti
communiste de dire nous renonçons à
quelque chose qui est un des un des
piliers principaux d'un système
républicain la gauche vit dans le mythe
d'une armée populaire d'une armée en
armes citoyenne l'héritage de la
Révolution française la levée en masse
une fois voilà mais tout ça tout ça
relève du mythe total qui ne correspond
absolument pas à la réalité historique
mais elle baigne là-dedans et puis il y
a aussi dans une partie de la gauche
c'est quand même une génération qui a
connu le coup d'État au Chili en 73 qui
a connu la garde
Algérie une armée professionnelle est-ce
que ce sera pas une armée pchiste est-ce
que ce sera pas une armée bon il y a un
peu de ça la décision de supprimer le
service militaire n'avait rien
d'absolument évident parce que le
service militaire avait été conçu comme
une façon d'associer la population à la
défense c'était la grande idée de jores
on a perdu le lien étroit entre l'armée
et la nation le fait que les militaires
se sentent vraiment associé à la défense
du
pays jpin connaissait mon point de vue
mais en même temps il était soumis comme
Jacques chir qui le gouvernement de
droite à la
pression de la direction du budget qui
voulait faire des économies au moment on
venait de voter le traité de Maastrich
avec ses critères
astraignants tout cela pesait dans un
seul sens qui était la
suppression
[Musique]
donc on décide de poursuivre la réforme
et je demande à Lionel Jospin ben si tu
d'avis que on poursuive cette réforme la
solution la plus simple c'est qu'on
finisse le débat qui est presque achevé
sur le projet de loi de nos
prédécesseurs puisque la précédente
majorité avait porté un texte et avait
le parcours législatif c'était il était
à la veille de son adoption définitive
et alors là jpin me dit ah bah non parce
que il y a un changement de majorité
nous aurons forcément notre propre
présentation de cette réforme parce
qu'elle avait quand même des impacts
économiques et psychologiques dans la
population très importante donc on veut
représenter cette réforme à notre
manière et donc tu fais un nouveau
projet de loi ce que j'ai fait en
l'espace de quel quelqu semaines et euh
en vieux parlementaire j'avais déjà 17
ans de maison dans les deux assemblées
j'ai reçu évidemment tous les groupes
parlementaires pour dire qu'en
pensez-vous que que que proposez-vous
éventuellement en évolution par rapport
à ce qui a déjà été discuté et le
souvenir assez net que j'ai c'est que
les groupes de gauche ont en gros laissé
passer le groupe communiste était
défavorable mais a dit bon bah le
gouvernement prend ses responsabilités
nous nous opposerons pas et mais nous
n'en pensons pas moins et nous le dirons
et la droite et la droite m'a dit écoute
on continue mais s'il te plaît tu nous
débarrasses du rendez-vous citoyen qui
était une exigence de Philippe ségin qui
était nominativement un service
militaire de 5 jours perçu comme très
difficile à appliquer par les militaires
et donc dans ces conditionsl on a fait
le débat qui a abouti et un vote final
dans lequel la majorité nouvelle de
gauche a voté pour je crois sans
exception alors que il y avait des
réticences assez fortes et par contre
les deux principaux groupes de droite
RPR et UDF à l'époque ont voté contre
alors qu'ils avaient voté quasiment
l'équivalent au printemps précédent et
que les seules modifications avait été
fait sur leur demande alors devant les
sénateurs au mois d'octobre vous allez
arguer que le contexte géopolitique ne
justifie plus le service militaire dans
la discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Alain Richard ministre de la
Défense monsieur le ministre vous avez
la
parole le bouleversement stratégique que
nous avons connu à partir de 1989 remett
en cause la justification militaire même
de la conscription nous ne connaissons
plus de menac militaires directes et
massive sur le territoire national
menace face à laquelle l'armée de
conscription était la la réponse
cohérente avec le recul est-ce que vous
prononceriez encore une phrase comme
celle-ci mais bien sûr il n'y a plus de
menace militaire sur le sol national
alors il y a des menaces hybrides
c'estàdire que nous
avons un un risque d'action non étatique
par des groupes terroristes ou par des
groupes
télécommandés par une puissance hostile
qui peuvent survenir sur sur le sol
national et nous en avons vu des
réalisations mais
euh je crois que ce qui est survenu
depuis n'a pas invalidé le fait que nous
n'avions pas besoin de 500000 ou 600000
hommes et femmes sous les armes en
situation statique comme force terrestre
le conflit en Ukraine ça change quelque
chose
non sauf le fait que la loi prévoit la
possibilité d'un réétablissement du
service national N n'avons pas
d'obstacle
constitutionnel à rétablir le service
national en application des dispositions
du code actuel et c'est la raison pour
laquelle en particulier on organise un
système de recensement de l'ensemble des
personnes vers l'âge de 16 ans qui sont
susceptibles d'être appelés et donc ce
recensement doit être maintenu à jour
alors parmi les principales nouveautés
apporté à par ce projet de loi les 5
jours de rendez-vous citoyens devient
donc une jour journée d'appel et de
préparation à la défense pourquoi c'est
un peu court non alors bien sûr c'était
un peu court mais l'option que nous
avons retenue c'était une journée
d'information et de pédagogie pour
donner à une classe d'âge vers 16 ans
donc en fin d'étude
secondairire une une initiation disons
une mise en contact avec les forces de
défense de manière que au moins il ait
avec un passage dans un lieu militaire
pour un sentiment si vous voulez de
concret pour que chaque génération
garçon et fille et une un premier
contact avec la défense ce choix de
restreindre à une journée cette
formation d'appel et de préparation à la
défense il va vous être reproché lors
des débats parlementaires notamment par
la droite qui va vous critiquer je parle
du rapporteur du texte au Sénat ou du
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de défense on écoute
laissez entendre que les jeunes de ce
pays bénéficieront en quelques heures
j'allais presque dire quelques minutes
d'une véritable préparation à la défense
me semble à la fois inexacte et trompeur
qu'est-ce donc que l'appel de
préparation à la défense cette journée
comprise entre 8h30 et 17h devrait
consister à présenter aux jeunes tout
d'abord les enjeux de la défense en 2h
puis a consacré 45 minutes à des tests
de détection de l'ilettrisme a présenté
ensuite en 2hures l'organisation les
moyens les métiers de la Défense puis un
film de 30 minutes sur le devoir de
mémoire préparé par le Secrétariat
d'État aux anciens combattant sera
visionné avant que trois quart d'heur de
bilan et d'entretien ne viennent clore
cette journée en réalité très brève
oui simplement ce sont les mêmes groupes
politiques qui quand je les avais
questionné en disant comment on fait
évoluer le texte que vous avez déjà
débattu c'est eux qui m'avaient demandé
de mettre fin à la formule de la semaine
de préparation alors malgré les
oppositions qui s'expriment au Sénat ben
la loi finit par être adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale qui qui a le
dernier mot il faut alors mettre en
œuvre ce chantier de la transformation
de l'armée quelle difficulté principale
allez-vous
rencontrer nous avons dû mettre fin à
probablement 400 ou 500 sites militaires
le nombre de régiments allait baissé le
nombre de bases aériennes allait baissé
et à chaque fois avec des effectifs plus
concentrés qui avaient des sujets de
mobilité des personnels en place et les
difficulté
de de gérer de façon positive la
libération de tous ces espaces nous
avons actuellement 124 régiments et qui
sont répartis en France métropolite are
mer ou à l'étranger en Allemagne en
Afrique et nous devrions ramener ce
chiffre à aux environ de 83 85
euh il y a une question alors ça pose
immédiatement chacun le comprend un
problème d'aménagement du
territoire parce que cela veut dire que
nous allons supprimer un certain nombre
d'unités de régim pour certaines villes
se sont c'est c'est quelquefois des
vrais drames d'ailleurs parce que il y a
euh quelquefis c'est toujours c'est une
garnison c'est une école c'est des
commerces c'est toute l'économie d'une
région qui peut en sour c'est la raison
pour laquelle je voudrais simplement
dire deux choses la première c'est que
je le répète c'est un programme é allé
sur 6 ans ce n'est donc pas
demain et deuxièmement nous allons
prévoir une organisation très structurée
pour tenir compte dans un dialogue
permanent avec les élus locaux avec tous
les élus locaux pour tenir compte de ces
évolutions et faire en sorte que grâce à
un aménagement volontaire du territoire
les villes ou les régions dans
lesquelles des unités seraient supprimé
garan ne soit pas pénalisé bonjour
Gérard Longuet bonjour vous avez été
député sénateur de la meu vous avez été
membrre de plusieurs gouvernement et
notamment ministre de la défense mais en
1997 quand la loi est votée vous êtes
président du conseil régional de Loren
une région qui va être lourdement
touchée par la restructuration de la
carte militaire qui a accompagne la
professionnalisation des armées est-ce
que vous avez été associé oui il y a eu
beaucoup de bonne volonté de la part de
l'armée mais les réalités sont les
réalités non seul vous avez un régiment
en moins bah vous le perdez quand vous
avez une agglomération comme Nancy ou
mes elles absorbent la la perte de d'une
ou deux ou voire de trois unités quand
vous avez des des villes beaucoup plus
petites je prends l'exemple de commerc
1000 habitants et un régiment
d'artilleur de d'à peu près 1000
artilleurs là c'est un choc adieuse en
Mosel par ex die c'est une tragédie
c'est le symbole et le poumon économique
de toute une ville le 13e régiment de
dragon parachutiste le 13 comme on
l'appelle ici est implanté à dieuse
depuis 1963 son milliers d'hommes et
leurs familles représentent plus du
quart de la population autant dire que
l'éventuel déménagement du régiment dans
le sud-ouest de la France laisserait ici
un très grand vide ça me fait mal cœur
oui c'est sûr que on perd beaucoup de
gens de des personnes qu'on connaît bien
et puis l'armée c'est quand même encrée
en dieuse
dieuse a déjà pas grand-chose alors si
en plus l'armée part c'est vrai que
c'est quand même je vais pas dire que
c'est la caserne qui fait viv dieuse
mais presque quoi ce régiment est
maintenu mais il est déplacé dans le
Sud-Ouest alors évidemment les gens
dieux sont sont découragés toute notre
armée fait une sorte de mouvement de
pivot du nord-est vers le sud-ouest
pourquoi parce que une armée de d'OPEX
c'est une armée de parachutiste c'est
une armée mobile c'est une armée de
petites unités très spécialisé très
formé et
euh le le le le car nordest de la France
la Lorine l'Alsace la Picardie tout ça
champagneardain évidemment tout ça perd
des garnisons Chalon en Champagne je
crois qu'il a quatre ou cinq unités il
en reste plus qu'une donc à Verdin nous
avions trois régiments complets il en
reste un
vous arrivez au ministère de la Défense
en 2011 on est 14 ans à peu près après
la la la décision de
professionnalisation de l'armée dans
quel état trouvez-vous les armées
françaises quand vous
arrivez une armée très professionnelle
et qui euh à condition d'être soutenu
matériellement et politiquement croit
dans sa mission et a les batailles je
sais pas ce qu'on dire sndicales euh
j'ai un immense respect pour le chef
d'état-major des armé pierredevillier
euh mais c'est un chef syndicaliste
quand je suis ministre il vient
pratiquement toutes les semaines dans
mon bureau m'expliquait qu'on en fait
pas assez pour l'équipement pour les les
la gestion des hommes pour les les
revenus pour les conditions matérielles
il a T non il a raison il a raison mais
on peut pas tout faire tout le temps
justement on peut pas toujours dire oui
quoi voilà est-ce que les ambitions
n'ont pas été trop revues à la baisse je
vous cite un extrait d'un rapport de la
Cour des comptes qui paru en en mai 2022
le ministère des armées a perdu 63000
emplois entre 2008 et 2019 soit 20 % de
ses effectifs entre 2003 donc au début
de la professionnalisation et 2020 le
nombre de charlescler est passé de 406 à
222 celui des avions de combat 393 à 261
celui des frégates de premier rang de 17
à 15 aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il nous
manque des Lecler le le ceux qui
redistribuent les cartes permettez-moi
de le dire euh c'est en effet le 24
février 2022 la situation a changé avec
l'agression de la Russie complètement
complètement parce qu'on s'est aperçu et
là mais la Cour des comptes ne le dit
pas que le risque en baissant la garde
c'est évidemment de tenter celui qui a
les moyens de de de de vous affronter de
le faire bon mais il est évident que si
on change complètement de perspective de
conflit nous n'avons pas l'armée
construite pour des batailles de char
dans les grandes plaines de l'est
européens aujourd'hui c'est un deuxème
chantier de prof de professionnalisation
de l'armée qu'il faut ou c'est plus de
moyens plus de moyens humains il y a un
truc qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que si il y avait une agression ça
voudrait dire qu'il y a eu conflit en
Allemagne conflit en Pologne conflit en
Hongrie donc il y a un temps d'alerte et
à ce moment-là c'est la dissuision qui
qui qui qui prend le relais ça veut dire
que la menace est suffisamment forte
pour qu'elle soit l'objet d'une riposte
par dissuasion vous parlez de la
dissuision nucléaire ça veut dire qu'on
a'urait pas besoin de lever en masse on
aurait pas besoin de rétablir le service
militaire non parce qu'on aurait pas le
temps nous avons quand même une doctrine
de défense qui reste fondée sur la
dissuasion nucléaire
et cela relativise ce que j'ai dit à
propos du service
nous ne sommes pas obligés
d'avoir une armée de terre de 200 300
400000 hommes mais nous aurions
certainement besoin d'avoir une armée
classique plus importante de façon à ne
pas nous laisser entraîner dans une
escalade dont nous n'aurions pas les
moyens en 2017 le candidat Emmanuel
Macron avait proposé dans son programme
de rétablir un service national
universel d'un mois pour tous les jeunes
et vous êtes endu à l'époque d'un billet
sur votre blog que j'ai retrouvé en
qualifiant ce projet d'inutile coûteux
n'ayant aucun intérêt pour l'armée
absolument on ne rétablira jamais le
service militaire on peut rétablir alors
ce que l'on peut faire c'est faire de la
préparation militaire à la Suisse avec
des réservistes qui choisissent un
régiment c'est d'ailleurs il y a 50000
un peu plus de 50000 réservic de l'armée
de terre qui sont utilisés et le seul
frein c'est un frein financier parce que
il faut les indemniser pour les journées
passées mais par exemple vous avez des
médecins c'est formidable qui font de la
réserve en opération rétablir le service
militaire pour toute une génération au
cas mais ça pas de sens parce que si si
vous formez des jeunes qui ne
reviendront pas dans le régiment les
forz pour rien une séance de tir ça
coûte de l'argent ça demande du matériel
c'est
dangereux si vous avez des jeunes qui
s'engagent par une préparation militaire
devenir réserviste militaire pendant 5
ans ou 10 ans là vous êtes gagnant mais
le président Macron n'a pas fait son
service militaire ça lui manque un petit
[Musique]
peu gouvernement de la
[Applaudissements]
République de
disposition s'il ne fallut que quelques
secondes à jaces shirac pour annoncer la
fin du service militaire il aura fallu
en revanche plusieurs années à la France
pour se doter d'une armée de métier avec
son lot d'effort de réussite de
déconvenu aussi l'armée française a été
largement mise à contribution depuis 20
ans que ce soit sur notre sol après les
attentats par exemple ou hors de nos
frontières pour des missions de maintien
de la paix ou de lutte contre le
djihadisme mais en se professionnalisant
l'armée aussi perdu une autre de ses
fonctions moins guerrière celle-là celle
de rassembler des générations de jeunes
Français sous les couleurs de la
République bonjour bénéct Chéron bonjour
vous êtes historienne maître de
conférence à l'Institut catholique de
Paris vous êtes une spécialiste du lien
armée société et on a beaucoup évoqué le
caractère militaire de cette réforme
dans cette émission je voudrais aborder
avec vous un autre aspect qui est
l'aspect citoyen de l'appel sous les
drapeaux le 28 mai 1996 quand Jacques
confirme la suspension du service
militaire il fait référence à cette
dimension
regardez pendant près d'un siècle la
conscription a mêlé dans la fraternité
des casernes des jeunes de toute
conditions venu de toutes les régions
elle a permis de défendre la patrie dans
les heures les plus tragique de notre
histoire et les noms inscrits sur les
monuments au
de chaque ville de chaque village nous
le rappelle avec
force si le service national
est peu à peu devenu
inadapté je dois et je veux défendre
l'idéal républicain auquel il se
réfère qui est un idéal
d'égalité un idéal de
solidarité un idéal de
patriotisme j'ai deux questions est-ce
que c'était aussi ça le service
militaire est-ce que c'est encore ça en
1996 alors ce qui est vrai c'est que le
service militaire s'inscrit vraiment
dans une mythologie républicaine souvent
on pense à l'héritage révolutionnaire en
fait le modèle du service militaire
français du 20e siècle c'est bien
davantage un modèle qui s'inscrit dans
l'histoire de la 3e république mais qui
explique aussi sa dimension un peu
mythologique parce qu'on sait que la 3è
République pour les Français c'est la
construction de unité de la nation
autour d'un régime qui est peu à peu
accepté avec l'école le service
militaire ça veut dire que cette
fraternité des casernes qui JAC sherac
elle a existé alors
il y a il y a deux choses il y a le
récit qu'on fait de cette histoire et
puis il y a les réalités vécues les
réalités vécues dans les casernes elles
sont évidemment des réalités très
diverses et très contrastées il n'y a
aucune armée au monde que ce soit des
des armées de conscrit ou des armées
professionnel qui échappe par exemple à
une forme de reproduction de la société
dans l'armée donc les hiérarchie sociale
qui existe dans une société se retrouve
toujours peu ou prou dans les milieux
militaires alors qu'on évoque
précisément le brassage social alors de
fait les gens se rencontraient dans les
casernes mais ne se rencontraient pas
tous à égalité pour les militaires comme
le général Puga par exemple ça existe le
brassage social on l'écoute moi j'ai
j'ai commandé des appelés dans les
années je dis 76 77 78 des gens qui
venent du Nord et cetera certains
n'avaient jamais vu la mer certains
n'avaient jamais vu la montagne et
certains ne savaient avz même pas taper
dans un ballon vous leur appreniez à
jouer avec un ballon et à la fin c'est
eux qui vous battaai à plat de couture
parce qu'ils étaient très doués
simplement on leur avait pas appris quel
souvenir gardez-vous de votre service
militaire cela vous surprendra mais
plutôt bon service militaire au 35e
régiment d'infanterie à Belfort sous les
ordres de l'udent chef bot par ailleurs
grand lecteur du Canard Enchaîné c'était
curieux mais ça vait la peine d'être
fait alors en fait ce brassage social il
mériterait d'être analysé un peu en
finesse on a quand même pas mal
d'éléments de récit hein d'anciens appel
et cetera qui montre que c'est une
expérience positive ou négative pour les
uns ou pour les autres ça dépend
évidemment des parcours du lieu où on
fait son service de ce qu'on est de la
manière dont on le vit mais qu'une fois
que le service est fini ça reste comme
une expérience ponctuelle sans forcément
de conséquences durables dans le temps
les politiques au fond n'ont pas eu
grand mal à supprimer le service
militaire mais ils ont eu beaucoup de
mal à trouver quoi mettre à la place
pour maintenir cette espèce de de lien
armée nation il y a eu l'idée d'un
rendez-vous citoyen qui a été abandonné
par une journée d'appel et de
préparation à la défense des
propositions de service CIVI comment ça
s'explique qu'on est toujours tourné
autour euh ce qu' ce qu'on constate
c'est que dans tous les pays européens
où on supprime les services militaires
entre les années 50 et et la fin des
années 90 en fait on est plutôt dans les
derniers la question de mettre autre
chose à la place se pose parfois dans
certains pays
les Britanniques ont été beaucoup plus
pragmatiques que nous quand en 57 ils
suppriment le service militaire ils
considèrent qu'ils n'ont plus besoin de
militaire qui n'ont plus besoin d'une
armée de masse et qu'ils ont besoin de
main d'œuvre dans l'industrie il ne
cherchent pas à remplacer par autre
chose il y a très peu de mythologie
autour du service militaire en
Grande-Bretagne nous il y a une
mythologie qui est celle de la 3è
République et donc il y a l'idée qu'il
faut mettre autre chose à la place mais
en fait dans les pays où on se pose la
question de ce autre chose à la place du
service militaire on se rend compte que
rien ne fait jamais suffisamment
consensus pour parvenir à imposer des
dispositifs généralisés qui seraient
autre chose que le service militaire la
patrie en danger le service militaire
fonctionne tant qu'il y a un relatif pas
généralisé évidemment mais un relatif
consensus sur la nécessité d'une armée
de masse pour se défendre contre une
invasion du territoire les services
civiques ou les services civils
souffrent d'un déficit de consensus
parce que la finalité ne peut pas faire
consensus ce qu'est le civisme dans une
société démocratique repose pour une
part sur des cvages idéologique on ne
voit pas le civisme de la même manière
selon qu'on soit de droite ou de gauche
par exemple et donc l'idée d'imposer un
service civique
obligatoire est une idée qui est
toujours très fragile parce qu'il n'y a
pas de consensus social suffisant pour
l'imposer donc c'est pas simplement que
les politique ont manqué d'ambition au
nom de quoi on imposerait au nom de quoi
on imposerait à chaque classe d'âge de
faire quelque chose sans qu'on sache
très bien d'ailleurs quoi parce
qu'est-ce que c'est la même chose par
exemple de rendre service à une
administration publique et de s'engager
dans une association mais si on Et si on
impose à chaque jeune de rendre service
dans une association au moment du
passage à l'âge adulte quelles sont les
associations à qui on reconnaît le
brevet de bonne citoyenneté et donc ça
suppose d'entrer dans une logique de
sélection des mission que l'on considère
comme étant conforme à une définition du
bon civisme et on voit bien que la
définition du bon civisme reste y
compris dans la République française un
sujet de débat permanent mais les
militaires d'aujourd'hui ils n'ont
aucune envie d'animer des camps de
vacances ou des colonies alors les
militaires d'aujourd'hui disent nous on
était plutôt pour le maintien du service
militaire mais si ça n'est pas le
service militaire nous n'avons pas
vocation à nous engager dans un
dispositif qui ne serait pas un service
militaire parce que notre métier c'est
de former une armée capable de défendre
le pays ou les intérêts du pays capable
de faire la guerre pour le dire
prosaïquement et non pas de participer à
l'éducation de la jeunesse par des
dispositifs dont la nature n'est pas
militaire dont la finalité n'est pas
militaire mais les l'idée d'un service
civil ou civique obligatoire qui en fait
est celle portée par le service national
universel voulu par le Président de la
République qui en fait n'est pas un
service militaire mais qui joue sur
cette mémoire du service militaire c'est
sûr que les armées sont plutôt peu
allentes pour encadrer un tel dispositif
parce que sa finalité n'est pas
militaire et alors j'ai regardé dans le
paysage politique c'est une proposition
qui revient tous horizons confondu
Marine Le Pen le propose en 2015 le
rétablissement du service militaire le
Parti socialiste le propose en 2016
Emmanuel Macron le propose en 2017 pour
un mois Jean-Luc Mélanchon le propose en
2020 comment ça s'explique ça s'explique
parce qu'encore une fois il y a une
mythologie qui est très puissante il y a
une histoire une mémoire plus qu'une
histoire il y a une mémoire du service
qui est très puissante en France et qui
qui est particulièrement puissante dans
les moments de crise quand une société
se perçoit en crise pour continuer
d'exister elle a besoin d'un récit des
origines de savoir d'où elle vient et le
service militaire a constitué au 20e
siècle l'un des ferments de continuité
de la nation autour de la République et
donc cette demande politique de faire
intervenir les armées dans des chantiers
de politique intérieure elle vient
contrairement à ce qu'on pense encore
une fois abîmer la relation entre les
Français et leurs armées parce qu'elle
vient introduire un doute sur le fait
que les armées ne sont pas liées à une
majorité ou à un camp politique mais
sont celles de toute la nation et donc
là il y a un vrai sujet c'estàd que plus
on engage les armées à des fins
éducatives à des fins de cohésion
sociale plus on introduit ce doute oui
la page a été tournée il n'y aura pas de
retour à au type de service militaire
obligatoire l'absence de service
militaire fait que le lien avec la la
l'armée a complètement disparu alors
vous avez toujours des nogique des gens
qui pensent que l'armée permettait de
dresser les jeunes mais on n'est pas du
tout dans des logiques militaires là on
est dans des logiques de comment dire de
de contrôle social pour moi les armées
aujourd'hui ont le le mental
l'état d'esprit le matériel l'équipement
l'entraînement pour faire face bien
regardez l'Ukraine se trouve bien
d'avoir maintenu une forme de service
militaire comme la Russie d'ailleurs
c'estàd que ça lui a permis de monter
rapidement en puissance et d'ajuster son
volume de force à l'ampleur de
l'agression
subie la fin du service militaire est un
vrai paradoxe politique c'est sans qu'on
teste la plus grande réforme du premier
mandat de irac mais depuis sa mise en
œuvre elle n'a cessé d'être discutée
voire critiquée les Français eux-mêmes
dans les sondages semblent avoir fait
volte face oubliant un peu vite que pour
beaucoup d'appelés ces longs mois passés
dans les casernes étaient souvent vécu
comme une contrainte inutile plutôt
qu'un apprentissage de la défense ou de
la citoyenneté c'est sans doute le signe
qu'avec la fin de l'appel sous les
drapeaux c'est un peu de notre
mythologie républicaine que nous avons
abandonné et que rien depuis n'a su le
remplacer c'est le signe aussi que la
situation a changé le conflit en Ukraine
a de nouveau fait réson donner le bruit
des armes aux portes de l'Europe et le
sentiment de cohésion nationale n'a
jamais paru aussi délité voire fracturé
dans notre société reste à savoir si ces
enjeux cruciaux se régleront par de
nouvelles réponses ou de vieilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
recettes
[Musique]